today's guest is a really uh uh is a
unique man
they would say if you saw something
and it is uh he was from the north and
now he's a southern man he's a
dir he's dual hemisphere man now you may
know him from his uh
flagrant 2 podcast with akash singh or
his brilliant idiots podcast with
charlemagne the god
or schultz says america on netflix it is
my friend comedian
andrew schultz
[Music]
[Applause]
just
do you look what a molly bro you're
coming in
boy how dare you going dog
i know you're trying to get the blanket
you gotta get diversity
i start filing firing all my minorities
yeah
dude i got this covered boys yeah you
start wearing one of the coming to
america hats i saw some guy one of those
today
dude yo
i got some of my teeth bro do you i
think i'm gonna i'm gonna get it out
with this
but whatever we're going yo shout out to
nate barghotzi man yeah shout out today
burgati man he got that new special
that's out um
i don't even know the name it's uh most
american man or something
yeah the best average american something
like that
yeah which is good i like it yeah it's
good stuff man
um i just love nate yeah dude he just
described him in the funniest way
i don't know if we were recording for it
yeah he's my he
yeah you said that you and i are neat we
need something from the audience i need
to see the audience doing something yeah
and nate could probably perform we were
saying
he did the show the special with the
masks yeah and i'm like yeah he could do
that
he could do his jokes if people were
laughing or not and he could perform
them in the same way yes and he'll be
fine yeah you and i would have a
meltdown yeah
if they were wearing masks just in our
own heads like they're laughing what the
[ __ ] are they squinting
what's wrong with these [ __ ] people
yeah what's that guy thinking about yeah
nate could perform for reforestation
like he could perform for like
you know like a to p like a fall you
know he just yeah he doesn't need
that right he doesn't need that heavy
feedback yeah
um god bless him yeah dude i want to
come down there i just love y'all's new
set man even though
it's on ig yeah it just looks like we
need you down there it makes me want to
do some uh
cappu or a dog and order um
you know what um caipirinha yeah
some capoeira and a caipirinha yeah dude
it makes me want to do that
uh and i see you guys are renting what
are y'all renting a palace or something
like that
there's a palace a little
we're in the hood though to be honest
are you yeah oh yeah but it looks like
it's not
oh yeah dude yeah it looks nice man
yeah i like going down there man um
yeah what's going on bro i mean just
chilling dude living life getting some
sun
out here doing shows have you thought
differently since being in miami like
has it started to adjust your view of
like
do i need to be in new york bro i was
thinking this on the way here like if
there's
one positive to corona um it's i made a
lot of money
no if there's a if there's one positive
to corona i think it's people from new
york
and in la realize that
oh there's other places in america that
are really nice to live
yeah and i didn't have i had that
attitude when i was growing up and then
i kind of like got out of new york and i
have family it's not from new york so i
like saw their other like really cool
places in america but like i know that
attitude because i grew up with that
attitude
right and um yeah just going down to
miami and like just
really enjoying living in a [ __ ]
house yeah and like having to drive to
work and then going
it's nice taking half an hour just
collect my thoughts
you know yeah dude it's dope well
especially for somebody coming out of
the city i mean that's gotta be a really
different inner city is great but it
sucks yeah like it's the worst place to
live
it's not how human beings should live
yeah you've been in new york
yeah i've been in new york man oh i
remember i was doing drugs i was staying
at ari shafir's old place dude before he
freaking
uh did that uh epithet for kobe or
whatever he did whatever it's called
before he spoke at his funeral yeah yeah
and uh
uh i got locked out of there dude i had
to climb they have like these communal
gardens or something
it's like you know sometimes no they
don't
they do though they have like there's no
communal cars
stopped
like bro it was insane it was just crazy
yeah yeah i knew it was just a lot bro
you're sweating this is a lot going on
for even somebody that's not i feel like
i almost got wrapped up in one of your
stories it almost happened just right
there
bro it almost happened right there
because it sounds like
it sounded so romantic fantastical that
i was like oh tell me about new york
[ __ ] communal cars at 12th and sea
there's a [ __ ] communal garden or
somebody burned a building down
the street yeah dude anyway i had to
jump a fence i just sneak around the
back of his building to get in
yeah um yeah but i i thought new york
city's hard bro
i think if you get older it's got to be
tougher okay what if it's not
older what if it's like um you start
achieving
some of your dreams and then you're like
how much do i want to live in the grind
to get to the place where i want to be
because it is the place for the grind oh
the grinder yeah
yeah you're a pa you're a coffee bean
dog you're [ __ ] getting in there
you're really just getting rent
yeah you get non-stop dude yeah and it's
worth it because you get to put you know
do all the
sets and [ __ ] like i remember seeing you
run around the city you know i should go
over out there to l.i.e to that other
place out there they had
dude that's the crazy one new york the
the the the room will be
30 feet by two and a half feet you're
right
yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
remember how crazy that [ __ ] is
she had to set the drinks on her
shoulders and then walk sideways
egyptian
yeah yeah
dude nate bargassi murdered in that room
bro oh i could see that
i could see that yeah he's so calm yeah
nate is that calm man i bet him donating
blood it could be
it could be an afternoon yeah yeah but
it could be he donates double
it's a while though his blood don't even
care to go
what are we doing here nate you know
yeah he's a call man he's the middle of
a storm that guy he's good at
just staying uh staying calm man um
we had a question that came up uh um
riley mao's here with us today and uh
and why don't you bring something up
riley we got a fella that from the mta i
know that brought in a question here
it's an urban gentleman kind of
a suburban gentleman no urban this guy's
urban
oh urban gentleman there we go riley get
it out okay
that's it huh did you ever move back to
kelly
well let's see what this guy has to say
sorry brandon the bike the podcast is
off
it's just going to be some sting brandon
oh it's been staying for a couple weeks
over there
you and chris you better eat some weird
[ __ ] hey what's on the menu
what's on the menu next week
they're probably getting freaking
ridiculous
get out of here get the volume on riley
no hold on so you're not going back bro
you're not going i'm going back dude
[ __ ] you bro this is a question turn the
question on right i can't even throw my
mic because
there's no sun coming out either fix the
damn deal i couldn't even throw my mic
away because
y'all made fun of me for the way i laugh
on the podcast who did you
shut the [ __ ] up
that is you oh yeah
who said that who did that one i did
that's awesome bro
find a better way to fix it riley yeah i
know that's what i'm trying to do okay
i was crying sorry man this question was
probably these kids you got working here
bro
like 12 years old it's getting bad you
got a little peter pan factory going on
dude what's going on that's
the one thing you find out outside of
l.a in new york dude it's young
boys we got a question that came in
right here for you so
okay okay what's up theo what's up has
you should
boy more faith from new york city hall
i'm ripping that
mta header yang baby let's go actually
[ __ ] them
this is a shitty organization to work
for anyway
anyways my question has you man i've
been watching you ever since like
[ __ ] guy code man you've came a long
way
brother yeah anyways my question for you
is
who do you think you are bro you've been
[ __ ] on new york ever since you left
man the [ __ ] is going on
cocaine we got hookers taxis everything
you went to man
yeah i'll be up there man i'll come
through
i'll be the white hesi bruh i'ma come
through and take that
i'm gonna come through and take that
land baby
i'm gonna come to it take that land baby
where you been at now is it true that
the university i have no clue is this
you have you been [ __ ] on new york
no i love new york man
i just love not new york too but you're
getting different though bro yeah i'm
different i'm tan bro
i look better tan bro oh you do i think
i look better
well you come in a lot more and i'll be
honest with you bro you come in a lot
more
i think mexican bro or [ __ ] beach
slavic
you know you know what i'm saying like
beach uh
croatian croatia beach
you crack them open there's a couple
brothers
there's a couple brothers in the rib
cage eating oranges bruh
russian little russian dogs oh okay
get a brown one eventually yeah oh
there's sheldrick
yeah that's a good question though man
like yeah well
it makes me think i love new york but
i'm a complete hypocrite bro
tell me this have you been able to get
different uh sorry interrupted
have you been able to get different
guests down in miami that you wouldn't
have been able to get
not really i mean like we had we had
your boy you got to tell me what
happened with chris hansen bro
because we had chris hanson yeah and
then everybody kept hitting me like yo
tell him to pay back theo i was like for
what like did
i thought they said tell them to pay
back theo
and i didn't know if like you were
involved in like to catch a predator in
some way or
no i've never done anything like that
okay so like no no i'll be honest bro i
had one
he should show up here though one girl
sent me a message on ig and i said
you are too young for me now
could he she work for you with the rest
of the [ __ ]
children that you have in there dude
that kid is of age how old he doesn't
even know what the [ __ ] pythagorean
theorem is
there you go great too he's hairless too
all right and look i'll tell you this
never uh he's hairless so he looks
younger got his first pass
he would be a great stunt man for a
chris hanson uh
i asked hanson who picks the adult
children
what did he say he didn't answer that's
a weird casting job
yeah like you look young enough i guess
yeah
how do you do that you go out to bars
and just kind of see who looks real
young
i don't like that kind of stuff when
somebody looks too young yeah it's weird
especially as i get older they're just
there there becomes this
like uh this governor in your head that
tells you
this is someone who has a book bag yeah
you know
yes like that's where it is for me if
somebody has a book bag
yes for any reason yeah right even night
school whatever it is for any reason
i know i don't i don't like
kids and you don't like people
furthering their education around their
job right right like i understand you
have like a tough job and you want to
like
be a nurse yeah but that's not for you
yeah that's not for me yeah yeah yeah
i just that's one of the deterrents for
me i feel like is a book pack you know
yeah i think that's a good one yeah
that's a good thing it keeps me that
stuff keeps me safe
because without the backpack you'd be
like i need you
well
[Laughter]
it's dangerous out there yeah yeah yeah
yeah
you look you lucky you got it fianceed
out
i i did get so you took i'm not gonna
say you took the easy way i was like you
took the
easy way oh bro
no you left the rest of us out here in
this barnum and bailey ass
[ __ ] i'm 17 i'm 27.
yeah not universe like you know it's
true you left it weird
i'll ask you this yeah well what
happened to me chris hansen was this
yeah and there was
we put him up i'll ask you this this is
what happened
probably impossible to talk to you
you're possible
okay tell me what happened with chris
hansen because i got inundated with
messages people are upset at me
for interviewing this guy because i
didn't know
that he i guess ripped you off or
something there was
extra charges at his room where'd you
put them up
we put them up at the four seasons
that's a that's you know i mean
you know oh look bro jose you don't made
it hey
you don't made it bro four seasons look
bro
we put them up at least the three
seasons and we got all four
according to those charges
now we put him up with the three seasons
he ordered the fourth that's what i'm
saying brother
how much extra charge it was about
twelve hundred dollars for autumn
that's what it was no including room
there was extra charges so that's where
it became a discrepancy where it
seemed like he was trying to not pay the
extra charges
okay and we kind of agreed on what the
charges would be so yeah
he felt like there was maybe gray area i
don't know i'm not accusing him
it just seemed obtuse at the end i
thought because the story i heard
the way that you know the game of
telephone changes [ __ ] is that um
he tried to sneak out the hotel and you
had like an
employee chase him down
yeah like on some not so fat like
remember your show sir like
like how ironic he leaves the hotel he
got arrested
[Laughter]
and then forced him to pay the bill
before he left that's what i heard i
swear to god i'm not making
up any of this i swear to god and i got
like 10 or 20 messages
uh here's what happened i had an
assistant at the time yeah
and she uh was make i had her she was
checking out what the bill was what was
going
on yeah and she was literally talking to
the woman on the front desk as he was
leaving the hotel
and so it just so happened it just so
happened and so
the she like it was had to apparently
speak with the lady and say well can you
make you know
get a hold of him and get some charges
at him we gotta get some charges out of
them yeah you know
yeah but with that said i mean
the dude has done a lot for humanity and
i don't mind putting him up for another
couple nights isn't it
you know what i mean like there's a
little part of you that's got to go like
he stops so many pedophiles
oh totally like he shouldn't have to pay
for the hotel yeah but you were like he
should have to pay a little
he didn't stop enough i think
what if that's the new show where were
you when i was a kid
and it's just people it's just trashing
people
rolling up on chris hanson and john
walsh and just
sitting them down and saying look man
where are we
okay we asked him about the epstein [ __ ]
because it's weird
he did so much good yeah look chris
hansen look man i'll say this the guy
has done a ton of good stuff yeah like
to get in the way of those people and i
think a lot of those people are sick i
don't know if
a lot of people want to be touching kids
i think it's a sick it's a [ __ ]
sickness i don't think it's a choice you
make up in the morning
you know yeah yeah but so and the guy's
done a lot of stuff
man so chris no matter what happened bro
we'll
i'll put you up anywhere you want to
stay for a couple nights moving forward
dog you know what i'm saying you keep
the kids safe baby boy
that's what i'm talking about schultz
got you son wait why am i hitting on
this
you ran on
we've got you you got a kid right here
we've got two kids that you can save
right now chris come
too i'm not going to give the address
come to wedgewood
we out here this is our last episode
here actually chris yep okay
this is our last episode here man
where's the new one well i don't know
i'm not telling you
not telling brendan i'm not telling you
i tell the police because there's 15
more of his [ __ ] cousins in there
right now building this [ __ ] out
i'm not telling him chrissy d either
the first kid that greeted me i was like
oh he looks kind of young and this guy's
got on [ __ ] papers
like what do you have here chocolate
factory who's running this [ __ ]
hello is the grilly creeper growing um
dude he is how old are you man again 22.
22.
22. he's american dude yeah tell him
you're straight american aren't you i am
yeah i never said he wasn't american
there you go he was a boy
but look i know this racial connotation
to everything
okay that's what people see and he's
uh he's um
he's a good guy man good guy riley mao
an adult right riley
i am and where do you work at riley
in uh in nashville there you go
all right there you go let me ask you
this though this is pretty rehearsable
you guys been working on it in case the
cops come
i don't know what his [ __ ] problem is
where do you work at regularly riley
what does theo do after 10 30.
what do you work at regularly riley
before he goes to bed what's going on
what's his favorite snack
no i let him run around on my back for a
few minutes
i think theo likes cheerios
um here's what i'm asking bro
dude your mic is looking for you bro
it's just getting further
the other day you might put up a wanted
post it was you
on it have you seen
it's just you in the picture you're
hanging in front of me somebody got to
prank me where they just like cement
it in i go to push it away
it's the new shake weight
god i'm sure he did 212 mikes today
uh tell me this do you think yeah this
is obviously a problem in our community
of
men communicating with being able to
communicate with women who
may or may not be age do i forgive
christilia no that's not
asking okay i thought that's what you
said no no i'm not at all there's some
[ __ ] on your heart it seems like but
that's not what we're here for okay do
you
think still or not do you think that
chris and i are certainly but i mean
like we were never like
chris was hard to get close to yeah yeah
and i think chris will tell you that too
chris i mean like
as long as i ever knew chris he was on
he was just honestly meant he was on his
phone and he was hard to get to know at
all
really i always thought because the
outside perception was that
but you guys were homies yeah i don't
think that we're certainly like
we're certainly friends like i mean i
think that colleagues was that a better
word i think colleagues are better
colleagues yeah yeah yeah and i think uh
yeah i mean i think i would have
probably wanted to be better friends
yeah you know i just think like chris
was popular before i had any
popularity right you know and
he was hard to get to know you know
yeah but i think he was in his addiction
and i literally like
when i think back on it watching him
like text women it was like watching
somebody use heroin in front of you
don't think of it like that
you don't think like oh man look how
like literally he could not stop
yeah so you know and i don't even think
i'm talking out of turn like i suffer
from addiction so i know what it's like
to have to like
be in places where you feel compelled by
powers that are greater than you kind of
to do stuff a lot of empathy for that it
seems
i think i do bro yeah but here's my
question for you is this man
do you think there should be some
liability
for instagram and for these services
that allow people to connect
i don't think that you should be able to
follow anybody under 18. or communicate
they can't put a barrier between
young people and adults like how was
they can't go to a movie
if you're not 18 like you need your
parent to go to the movie with you
if you're under 18. but like instagram
this is what i think is the worst that
they're doing like snapchat and all them
is not only and snapchat is probably the
worst that's why i don't even [ __ ] with
snapchat but like
they are forcing you to see [ __ ] you
don't want to see
oh yeah yeah it's like a surprise here's
a child exactly here's a child
dancing suggestively and i'm like nah
bro this is [ __ ] it's weird bro
it's just weird dude yeah and here's a
child it's almost like a chinese like uh
information like data suck so i'm just
like [ __ ] that as well
yeah there's rumors of that i mean it is
it's not a rumor they're just like yeah
we built it but i love
all the data it's just people with like
pictures of like magical makeup on it
[ __ ] like no they're trying to turn
americans into pedophiles that's what
they're like they're like 14 year olds
dancing
isn't that cool isn't that awesome dude
everybody's
our [ __ ] president is sniffing
children's hair
how is that not our new national anthem
it's just him sniffing hair
to a [ __ ] trap beat dude that poor
did you see him just give up on his
speech the other day
anyway he forgot the word but
he forgot he's talking about he just
said
anyway
dude i'm shocked culpability you were
saying about the app
how is there not like how was there not
a class-action suit by any
parents that have ever had their kids
who have been approached
by adults through the app yeah that
that's not illegal i mean that's insane
right if you may if you made a pathway
if you allowed a company to dig a tunnel
from my child's bedroom
to a [ __ ] grown man's house dude i
would show up at the company and
assassinate everybody in that yes 100
that's what i would do 100 and that's a
problem with some of these shooters
they're shooting up the wrong
people people need to get shot people
asking for bullets
nah it's true now you make a good point
like why do we not look at them be like
why are you suggesting this [ __ ] to me
and then they blame it on you they go
yeah the algorithm knows what you like
no it don't stop showing me [ __ ]
you they removed the dislike button
remember there was a dislike button like
you're gonna get rid of it like
[ __ ] i can't even tell you to
not
show me young [ __ ] bro like i can't
even tell you to do that
you can remove my ability nah they're
[ __ ] up dude they're [ __ ] up
like you look at someone's explore page
it says a lot about them bro oh mine is
very
mine is all adult [ __ ] yeah yeah a
little bit of six
nine yeah okay yeah yeah
street fights yeah yeah a couple street
fights on there
and then like a couple of [ __ ] like
um
what else is on there oh i watched
carolyn's i was listening to calendar
steve's new stuff
yeah you guys's stuff is on there and
then women a lot of russian women that
have sent that little hand emoji to you
you do hand emoji that's your opening
yeah not only
as much i used to which is kind of nice
yeah for a while i was kind of like are
these women even
but now it's like some aren't even real
and doesn't matter
i just at a certain point for me it's
like giving away my it's like i'd rather
just keep my own [ __ ] chi
you know i'm not serving my cheat
through this [ __ ] dirty pipeline what
i'm saying
yeah yeah yeah what is it doing for me
what percentage of chi
are you giving with a hand emoji i think
you're giving away five percent of your
chi on that's
five percent i think so because it's
like do i have the control or not
to let this thing influence me that much
where i'm gonna drop a hand to this
romanian
i mean you're gonna drop a hand
regardless
right probably yeah but at least
it's rather not she knows about it
that's really what the hand is
like i'm gonna use this yeah yeah but
i'd rather like you know i'ma hold on to
this
i hear you i'ma keep a little bit of
that energy so when i meet a girl at a
cafe maybe there's a little bit more
hoots but behind my [ __ ] desire
than to think that i've been already
rejected 70 times
this morning you know what i'm saying
like i think some of that plays into how
we
operate you know you see something dude
he's been rejected 9
000 times that month and he asks you out
i think his energy is kind of probably
going to be whack
yeah you're probably right then then
again like you ever have one of those
friends that
uh is impervious to rejection
i'm not that friend but you know what i
mean like like i had a buddy growing up
who just could get rejected and it meant
nothing like he was more embarrassed if
he didn't go say hello
oh wow i wish i had that yeah yeah who
gave him that
uh jamaica oh is it uh
the comedian that was just here no no no
no no duval
no i love little dude i know i saw your
video i watched y'all's youtube videos
sweet bro
bro he is the goat little duval i'm
telling you is
operating on another level is he that is
that's he said
on another level and like you got to be
around him to get it and then when
you're around him you're going to really
understand it and he's just like
trying to communicate [ __ ] that he's
understood come up with in the most
digestible way possible but
if you just sit and talk with him and he
really kind of like gives you that part
of him
you're gonna go oh this guy is an alien
damn he's the closest to alien that i've
met
damn and no formal education
like he literally said like i didn't
have like meals until i was rich like i
grew up on appetizers
wow like the guy had nothing but his
just brain is different and he can
absorb everything and understand like
he's just [ __ ] genius that guy
yeah super genius yeah i wish i'd have
gotten to meet him
i'm gonna try to go i'm gonna go see him
next time he comes through yeah
um we got another question came in here
let's play another one here right
what we got right
and where have you been right you've
been doing a lot of church stuff or what
uh
no i've been doing a lot of uh music
videos okay church stuff
what do you do in the church i uh i run
audio and video
oh cool then you're an active member of
your congregation rally
what's that are you an active member of
your congregation yeah
the guys that built uh our studio in
brooklyn um
that's a big part of their business
doing av for churches yeah
yeah the thing about the church i like
the church show but here's the thing
about the church show
okay they start being too nice letting
too many people get on the stage bro
then they got to do with the bell they
got the handicapped dude they got the
sign language they got
the guy in the cage always like in the
uh screened off why is that guy in the
screened off stuff always
who knows nobody knows well somebody
should man if y'all are running proper
stuff up there there's just too many
by the end by the end of the year it's
like 19. it's just yeah yeah yeah it's
getting a little [ __ ] yeah yeah
i want to let you know that insurance
can be complicated yep
it can be it can be damn confusing
really insurance
you don't know if you're insured
somebody throws something at you you
hurt yourself
damn who do i call you're just calling
9-1-1 all the time
they're like we don't have we don't have
any coverage on you
and that's why um you gotta check out
the zebra
the zebra.com insurance finally feels
like it's in black and white
no more confusion just honest rates
the zebra is the nation's leading
insurance comparison site for car
and home insurance they can help you
save money today
it's so easy go to thezebra.com
and answer a few questions to compare
accurate insurance quotes
for free the zebra protects your
personal information
they don't sell it out there to the dang
snow cone stand or
you know to the tire shop so you got
somebody offering you ice cold tigers
blood tires
it's got to stop you can save as much
money as possible
how much can you save find out visit the
zebra.com
t-h-e-o that's t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a
dot com slash t-h-e-o
for insurance in black and white you may
see me meandering down the street
doing fitness running gunning
you may see me making moves
and i'm moving in fabletics
god you may see a damn flock of women
running behind me a flock of birds
geese baby geet mini geese
what i'm talking about is fabletics men
fablet x-men
represents for every guy who wants to
look and feel his best
oh he looks good ooh he feels good
they do it without breaking the bank
they keep it simple they cut the crap
they focus on what counts go to
fabletx.com
theo that's f a b l e t i c s
dot com slash theo to access an
insane deal stay hard get your first two
pairs of
shorts for just 20 fordala
when you become a fabletics men vip
member at checkout all styles all colors
no exclusions get the best activewear 20
to 50 percent off retail prices
every time you shop that's right become
a fabletics vip member you can find out
more about it
at fabletics.com go to fabletics.com
t-h-e-o for access to that
insane deal fabletics man
one guy play this beautiful guy right
here man what up theo
what up schultzies juan from
gansas out here and in this video good
to see my two favorite comedians
podcasters
on the same post let's go um the focus
i'm going to say
did you have that that that american
studio shout out to you i saw you in
kansas city
in the hedakova deal i haven't seen you
because you're scared to go out but
i see you posting those videos on
instagram i'll be out baby
um anyways andrew i'm getting married
this summer
any tips on the speech i was a
as a groom i want to give a speech
that's good man um
yeah why don't you how do you perform
that rooms give a speech
i thought you don't speak i thought
everybody else the friend speech
so yeah the guy doesn't know how it
works but that's his problem
you know what i'm saying yeah don't be
great if he gives his licenses
just don't give a speech because that's
how weddings work
yeah that's the advice bro there you go
everybody talks about you and then they
trash you and say that your wife is
amazing and then the wedding's over
yeah you don't say anything yeah it's
mostly just trying to you just guessing
if any of the dudes are ever hooked up
with your lady
that's what a lot of it is dude i'll be
at a wedding and i will tell the guy
i just want to let you know if the wife
has invited me because i'll get invited
by something about her wife's
i will say i have never had anything to
do with your wife
you just out of nowhere say that yeah
cause i feel like the guy if i'm the guy
[ __ ] him up on him the day of his
wedding where he's like why would you
say that to me unsolicited now i'm
thinking that you smashed my wife
oh yeah you can't be thinking like that
you got to think like i think like i'm
trying to let you know i want you to
feel
safe that hey buddy you know i just want
to let you know i'm just here for
food and to be supportive i've never had
i've never even seen your wife and what
if i'm like i never thought that you saw
her because you guys didn't grow up
together and you didn't even meet until
today so why are you
sharing this information yeah that's
true huh yeah cause i'm definitely gonna
think
that you made love to my wife
if you said that damn damn man yeah like
if i came in here and i was like um
all the boys that you have working here
at your factory they
never worked for me before you what
would you think
i feel like you know something about
these boys
i see yeah i gotta maybe i'll just have
to think about her
kind of do a pro con thing on it but
yeah maybe i uh yeah i like to say that
i'll say that to any girl i know who
has a boy around i will tell the dude
hey man i just want to let you know i
never had anything to do with your lady
even if it's a lie sometimes
i think i just want the dude to feel
comfortable wait do you have any friends
that are dating girls that you've slept
with
um i'm sure i probably do currently
um i don't know i don't have a ton of
friends at the moment i mean i have like
it's like i'm not in between friends but
it's her in cove but it's like there's a
couple guys who are your friends
i mean probably i probably have i have
probably
who's the next person you're gonna stop
being friends with do you have you
already figured it out
bro i can't get over how good the show
would be
where were you when i got molested
that's right we never got to that like
he did so much good but because he's the
guy that stops molesters
you're looking at like where like come
on bro
epstein was was added like what were you
doing
what about some kid who's getting lusted
he's just waiting for chris hanson to
come in the door because he saw the show
no ever nothing oh that's got to be
heartbreaking yeah
thailand imagine how many people see
chris hanson oh i hate even thinking
about this
this is the sick part about being alive
sometimes is the thoughts you have like
imagine how many people see christopher
hansen
and think man i got reminds them that
they got molested
yeah but you could also look at it like
you might have got molested double
if it wasn't for him for chris hanson
because maybe one of those other guys
would have been molesting but he stopped
it there's no doubt that he stopped
a lot of molesting yeah because those
guys just go it's just it's
like yeah yep it's yeah damn
it's thick stuff man what else we got
riley man i want to bring up another
question
here guys i don't know how to get out of
where we are
a lot of pressure on you today bro a lot
of pressure
here we go man yo theo
schultzy two of my favorites what i only
seen schultz live
this saturday night show in uh
in uh nashville let's go i saw theo a
couple years ago
in uh lexington that's what's driving
from louisville kentucky so i'm hyped
for all this
um but question here out of this
list who do you think is the most likely
to have a successful presidential
campaign
and all this is possible in the climate
we're in so here we go
alex jones dr umar
yeah do you know aoc or logan paul
okay what we thinking dr umar is that
woman right
no dr umar johnson pull him up
is raleigh the funniest guy
unintentionally on the internet okay
okay
he is he's the prince of pan-africanism
right
yeah so he's it's like uh it's it's
it's black empowerment and a lot of the
stuff that he says
is good it's right care about the
community do all these things but it's
to another level and
some might say that he's a bit of a con
artist he's gonna try to build a school
for just black boys and he's
getting this money to build the school
but the school has never has been built
and he is oh yeah why can you go to like
a doctor
johnson highlight reel yeah let's go to
youtube uh riley
oh my god dude i gotta bring up
something because it's just too good
it's it's too too good he's a legend
this guy
is a legend is he really undeniably
hilarious
dr umar johnson highlight video can you
get that yeah
give me a second i think there's also
like threads on uh
there we go hold up
oh god it's too good let's see which one
uh
let's do the top one there let's see
you're watching oh no this is just the
breakfast club interview
you need a highlight for him okay but
let's go back riley
yeah i wish i wish i had the video up oh
my god
hold on there we go part one hit it
all right let's see what we got how many
unconscious there's no cat no cap
i haven't gotten any donations lately we
need some donations
dollar sign fdmg school get them
donations in
if you want to donate to the black
parent tour to help dr uma with my
expenses
dalasana dr umar johnson dallasann dr
umar johnson
if you're a single beautiful
nappy-headed
intelligent voluptuous black woman send
me a resume
to dr umar johnson at yahoo.com if you
are a single
beautiful nappy-headed voluptuous
black woman send me a resume
i'm in your ass leave no honor i'm in
your ass
william clay i'm in your ass gerald
palmer
i'm in your ass aunt toss bengali who is
this the rapper
strong alpha males send those resumes in
fdmg resumes at gmail.com
and he has a lot of email addresses
doesn't he how hard is it so i can log
in it sounds like a [ __ ]
nightmare
all right maybe we didn't choose the
right highlight but trust me this guy's
pretty good i promise it's already
looking good
i wish we came with more heat bro i got
to come with the links next time
yeah i was kind of a bomb right there
it's kind of a big bomb i feel really
bad i know how important you know dead
air is on a podcast
what was the question i don't know dude
oh yeah
who would you want to be who is a
realistic uh
president president uh logan paul
probably you think i don't uh oh wait
logan maybe
the most realistic chance i thought the
other guy somebody just offered me a jet
from here to go watch the brother fight
alex johnson yeah wait alex jones no no
to watch the brother logan paul's
brother
oh oh jake yeah i can't decide if i'm
gonna go or not oh yeah if you can go go
are you kidding it's gonna be a great
it's gonna be a great event
you think so 100 yeah yeah maybe i'll go
yeah there's going to be like
performances and [ __ ] they know what
they're doing wait is it that triller
[ __ ] again
yeah oh dude i didn't like it bro i felt
like i was stuck at a [ __ ] nightclub
in jacksonville
that's the whole thing about my dude
maybe that's why i liked it
how's that some bad lights
and people [ __ ] basically look like a
couple of rappers wandering
around singing while they were looking
for their [ __ ] car keys
and then they would cut to some [ __ ]
box the boxing was [ __ ] bad i thought
it was bad
really yeah i loved it bro did you
yeah i really liked it i don't know why
i mean maybe it was just cool to see
mike tyson fight again
it was cool to see roy jones fight again
and then it was shocking to see jake
paul
just completely obliterate mae robinson
but uh dude a lot of people thought nate
was going to win that probably
yeah that's just racism yeah but that's
like
that was that's racism the other way is
that
it's like i can't beat a black guy in a
fight that's what
people just looked at they're like
there's no way that white guy can beat a
black outfit and then
people like yeah but he's like six
inches taller and he weighs more and
you know like yeah but he's a white guy
his name is jake
there's no way that he can win in a
fight and it turns out that [ __ ]
can fight
that's crazy bro that's the thing about
being able to fight you can't really
talk much [ __ ]
to that person afterwards like all the
people who just like clown jay paul and
make fun of jake paul
that kind of stopped like a famous p
like all of a sudden like snoop dogg and
[ __ ] or like
hanging with him like when he i remember
jake paul did a music video with like uh
gucci mane and everybody was like
teasing him and [ __ ] about it and now
all of a sudden
all these rappers want to hang out with
him right everybody wants to hang out
with the
the silverback man everybody wants to
hang out with the guy who's knocking
people out take a point huh yeah
i bet your boys going through that right
now who's that dustin
oh yeah i'm sure oh i know he's been
hacked yeah people have been trying to
get him to do everything
he said stop yeah driving gloves he said
somebody hit him up to model driving
gloves i'm like jesus man
for golf huh no for driving autos bro
like
the taxi kept driving new york like
roaring 20s kind of [ __ ]
whenever i get into a tax cabin i had
gloves i was like bro we're about to be
early
this guy came ready to work
bro who's playing
how strenuous is holding the wheel we
got power steering now dude
people drive with their knees dude
people who have no arms
and they go to work by driving with
their [ __ ]
feet and you got full-on gloves
to hold the wheel the wheel is made out
of gloves they made it easier for you
they just put the glove on the wheel
it's unbelievable what could it possibly
do after a long day drive you think you
take it off you're like thank god i'm
poor
i'm sweating he's in the laundry
but i think they're waiting to help you
like get like
no he's wearing weighted driving have
you [ __ ]
seen america talk people are wearing
complete [ __ ] there was a weighted
swimming
neck brace that two people [ __ ]
drowned in that they had a lawsuit like
eight years ago
why would wear weights in the pool
because they're [ __ ]
idiots here have you been alive
have you [ __ ] been outside of your
eyes no people are [ __ ] bro
awaited swimming to fight people are
legally [ __ ]
and then there's people that are just
after that yo that's the thing that's
crazy
is it like we have to decide when a
[ __ ] starts right and there are people
who are
just not recalling yeah we call them
normal
dude there's no that yeah that first the
first
little iq point right there those people
walking around
barely getting by yeah
like every once in a while want to make
one of the moans the
little [ __ ] jurassic park
there is a guy okay alan his parents
just
let him go outside and just [ __ ] turn
around and just look at each other
they gotta hold in that [ __ ] sound so
nobody knows
they gotta hold that [ __ ] out yeah just
looking around
[Laughter]
yeah dude that's like a mosquito dude
bro i realized yesterday how weird is
this tell me if this is not
yeah because you're the closest thing
you're the closest thing we've had to a
black guest in a while dude
is the u.s postal system basically just
like giving mail to a black guy and
hoping it gets where it's supposed to go
that's what i feel like
that's what i realized the other day
that the u.s postal system
today is basically just like hand in the
middle of a black eye
and hoping he cares enough for it to go
where it's supposed to go
is that not [ __ ] the truth
like go mail something bro
[Laughter]
go mail something yeah you might be on
to
no home or nothing but like it's [ __ ]
crazy bro
once you get lost bro i mean this it's
just
a lot of things right right bro u.s
postal system [ __ ] is right
it's 50. remember when trump tried to
fix it and then america was like
stop this doesn't work and they're like
stop
stop there and he was like he's like no
you understand like it's just handing it
to a black guy maybe he brings it and
then they're like
stop trying to make it better you
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are you thinking he's like
but maybe there's a better system even
for them like we could give him an
address or something
to get your postage to and america is
like
[ __ ] you for wanting us to get our mail
piece of [ __ ] yeah are you crazy guy
dude the anxiety of you
want a white male [ __ ] traveling
around the country anymore
this [ __ ] has to stop dude but just
imagine being that poor black guy
they just give you a satchel full of
[ __ ] and he like
do you know where where any of this
should go deliver it
yeah but i just wondering if if i should
shouldn't like where's where is there
like a route
dude how many black dudes out there are
just pretending there's santa every day
and just [ __ ] putting mail wherever
bro how many [ __ ] bro
bro have you ever seen it like a mailbox
racist or not bro but have you ever seen
them will they just let us know
every day i go to my mailbox and i'm
thinking there's going to be a letter
and it's just going to say yes or no
[Laughter]
but it never comes
just tell us man
that was a good laugh it was a good
laugh man
but we're no closer to an answer
we never will be man shit's getting wild
you know they said that
uh what did i see the other day they
think about doing a movie with black
christopher columbus which is [ __ ]
blew my mind you know
yeah i mean it's that's actually kind of
cool
you know i fell off at the black annie
so from the beginning i was out
you know like the force like the forced
because otherwise i want to see white
ammo stop you know what i'm saying i
want to see the other way i want to see
japanese amistad or i want to see
you know ginger amistad yeah you know
that would be that would be kind of sick
yeah ginger amistad
wouldn't that be crazy yeah a bunch of
gingers on a ship
yeah that's like vikings that was the
vikings yeah
right yeah but not doing well you know
we're having a tough
yeah being like steerage in steer and
steerage yeah
yeah you don't like to force diversity
i don't like it i just don't think i get
it i
get like there's some need for it in
some places but it's like
unless you're doing it everywhere i just
don't think it helps i think in the end
things have to be merit-based because
otherwise you can't say like at this
company
you gotta have this but over here on
this company donut you know it just kind
of
yeah and i think it rubs people the
wrong way after a while yeah i don't
think i don't think it works for anyone
because the the communities
that are being quote unquote represented
aren't
really being represented because they're
just taking a black person and making
them play a traditional white role yeah
like the black community is not going
yeah that's us they're going
no you're just acting like that white
guy yeah like hey alvin you're a
businessman today
he's like oh you know like when like if
you want to tell
a story about a black businessman you
could easily do that
definitely tons of stories yeah that's
what they're so [ __ ] lazy in
hollywood
and they're so racist this is how racist
hollywood they're like
wait do you think people would care
about a black person's story [ __ ]
just make them james bond right like
that that was like a hundred years of
hollywood
yeah that's what i don't understand how
black people are like so like
don't like don't say that hollywood give
like virgil tibbs was y'alls only dude
forever that's in the heat of the night
can you pull up virgil tips please
brother jesus christ man jesus can't get
this [ __ ] god at work
unbelievable
dude but yeah dude it is a little [ __ ]
up when you think about it like that
well it just doesn't behoove anybody i
don't know there you go virgil tip no
yeah dude this is from sneakers yeah
this is from in the heat of the night
yeah of course of course
but uh he was my favorite man oh no no
virgil tips whoopsie my bad
and that is uh hercule parrot i think
his other guy and that's from raisin in
the sun
first of all is raisin in the sun racial
terror i feel like can we
super racist but can i say what i said
was really racist but it wasn't
i said sneakers right because i was
thinking of sydney podie
right and i looked and i was like but
that guy looks like sydney [ __ ]
podium and then i was like oh [ __ ] am i
racist am i making two black people
no the third picture says what
underneath it
third picture sydney podium right so the
one that i looked at was
sydney podie well one of them is a movie
and one of the television show
yeah virgil tip virgil tibbs the
character right and
sidney protier played uh him in the
movie
ah i got you got you guys you got you
got you okay but
yeah i just and i love now how now
hollywood's like oh yeah
yeah that's a thing it's like yeah
i wish people would just understand
hollywood it's just yeah it's a business
i try to get attached more to it and
that's one of my problems sometimes i'll
attach more
yeah yeah yeah oh yeah man they don't
want me this and that they're just a
[ __ ] business that
thinks they're run really really that
thinks they're great that's also
a thing about them and it's one of those
things where like
i feel like they set it up almost like
mcdonald's where you know how and this
is not to insult [ __ ] work
mcdonald's but
anybody could work at mcdonald's um like
they set it up
so that yeah you're right actually
anybody can work at mcdonald's because
they even do they do everybody from down
syndrome hires
to uh full-fledged capable hires exactly
right
yeah so they're got the whole spectrum
and it's a brilliant business in that
way where anybody can go in there and
pretty much figure it out and then
you can improve and become a manager and
do all these other things but like the
lower level positions right there
anybody can kind of do and they set it
up that way
i feel like for a little while hollywood
set up the system
so well that they could insert whoever
they wanted
and it kind of worked out right like
there were a few actors and there were a
few like movie franchises and [ __ ] and
you were just like
do people like this guy like what the
[ __ ] but i'm still gonna watch it
because that's what's on tv
yeah you know and i do think that the
internet kind of exposed that
like when you think about it we just
talk [ __ ]
for hours and that's better than
a tv show that they spend tens of
millions of dollars
yeah like you and i have just made
[ __ ] sounds
there was a part of this podcast where
we just made restart sounds i made one
but yeah but you did a couple because
you could
you did a couple
okay you eat your weird foods we're out
here and we're making retards
you guys are bad friends
the [ __ ] out of here you guys are both
two guys that i told i wouldn't do
podcasts with
that's who you guys are
so let's [ __ ]
god's fired bobby lee you're taking that
santina are you taking that bobby lee's
not even awake right now
and it's 4 p.m in the afternoon guy
texted me at 2
49 am the other day asking me a normal
daytime question
what do you ask i love that [ __ ]
so much
i haven't seen you in a while yeah the
[ __ ] you talking about that's cause i'm
[ __ ] dayternal fam
tighten up dude oh [ __ ]
yeah man i don't know he runs a tight
[ __ ] bro i remember during corona i went
over there to do uh
his podcast and they were on a good ship
and uh him and his girl kalila
oh yeah yeah they're they're great and
uh and i came over i came with the crew
right and uh they wouldn't let the crew
in because of corona
wow yeah yeah they got real specific
they got a new home too
and they don't want a lot of people in
their new home i think her parents have
like potential co-morbidities
so she's taking it crazy serious and i
get that
yeah because you know that was back in
the day like if you're old you just die
at least that's what we thought so i do
understand that
but i was like okay look at how
responsible [ __ ] bobby is bro bobby
was the wildest boy
and now this guy's a grown ass
responsible man yeah man
i mean they're great they're really
great over there i love bobby
bobby i'll say this he always comes
through when you
when you need him bobby comes through
when you need him really yeah
has he been there for you he has bobby
comes through when you need him
um and it's fun man look we get to play
in this world of like
doing podcasts and like you know this is
absurd what we get to do we get to talk
to freaking legends
legends you know like i mean we get to
talk to legends
yeah you know like i got to talk the
other day we had bobby k
jude like bobby kennedy jr on right like
we had but i'm just saying like we had a
candidate he the anti-vaxx guy
yeah he's a vet he's safe safe what does
that mean
he just wants the vax to be tested for a
decent amount of time in decent way
before they give him to people
which isn't really bro crazy like why we
call him crazy
before you inject me with some crazy
[ __ ] can you like look at it a bit
like that dude who's running the
vaccination part of the usps bro is that
yeah just like take this [ __ ]
and [ __ ] it right do your best fam
do your best fam and this guy's out
there like yo can you just look in the
ingredients
can you look at the ingredients can i
get a nutrition facts
or whatever can give me the back of the
snapple bro
is that crazy you get a vaccine that
don't even have the back of the snapple
bro
that's not that is crazy bro it don't
even show your back
yeah yeah yeah just show me the back
where it says it got this much sodium
and this much sugar and this much added
sugar where the riboflavin's at dude
how many riboflavins you got
i think that's fair i think that's very
fair are you getting vacs
i don't want to come out as an
anti-vaxxer but i don't think
i would say no like i don't think i need
the vacs and i would like to wait a year
or two
to make sure everything's cool i grew up
in a community where they
the the when they had the vaccine for
polio
they created it in my community in
louisiana
and it gave cervical cancer to millions
of women
millions of women in america but the
government had already made it
they'd already created and spent all the
money to make so much of it
that they had they because it also got
rid of polio
but the cost was your [ __ ] got to get
taken out
you know what i'm saying i don't have a
buzzy man
i'm gonna be honest with you that sounds
like a fuzzy problem
as a non-owner
how great is 69 all he does is he walks
into a [ __ ] uh he walks in with
johnson and murphy at the airport he's
like y'all [ __ ] son
meek million [ __ ] i love it look at
this go right here
that two drops more hand bombs than
anybody
the most dude he's do you see a
documentary about him
the hulu one yeah no i haven't seen an
old one it was so great because it just
shows
yeah all these rappers are afraid to
kill anybody anymore because everybody's
making money
so now you can just rip him the shreds
and there's no consequences he found it
out
he figured it out and that's what i
appreciate about him so much is it like
i don't like uh how do i say this like
if you
made your wealth in blood money i don't
like you
morally grandstanding like i'm okay
if you make your money dirty but don't
tell me how to be
good right you know what i'm saying so
it's like it was a lot of rappers for
like a moment who like
their whole career bragged about
horrible [ __ ] that they were doing like
benny hen
i don't know who that is um he's not a
rapper but
like a speaker kind of go on anyway
afternoon i said nothing
anyway but but you know what i'm saying
it's like you if you talk about
how much you kill people sell drugs and
do that other [ __ ] and then you're also
like
we need to take care of our communities
it's like bro i've been listening to
three albums of you murdering your
community
now if you want to if you want to make a
change in your life that's great i'm
with it 100
yeah awesome like nos yeah boom
there you go or if you just want to tell
them i get that right yeah nice
yeah thanks right now we call knots but
like if you want to tell a story look
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do right
i could also go man shut your [ __ ]
ass up yeah
you know what i'm saying like it's like
i'm gonna sit down with orange juice all
of a sudden if i start selling orange
juice it's gonna
seem like come on man yeah you don't
really know anything about this
exactly especially if your whole life
you're like you you're
totally against fruit yeah yeah and i
don't care if you get proper nutrition
or [ __ ] beverages or not yeah it's
like for example if you like you rode so
hard from new york and you like swore
you would never leave new york you know
what i mean and then like a pandemic
came
and then you move to miami like that
type of person would be
a hypocrite yeah a piece of [ __ ] even
and i might not even ever listen to what
a guy like that would say
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] flagrant yeah
it would be super fun
it would be super funny like what an
[ __ ] that guy would be you know
like really realistically
yeah [ __ ] scumbag especially if he
was like yo anybody who leaves right in
new york right now is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm never leaving and even posted a meme
from the wolf of wall street about how
i'm not
leaving like if he did that type of
thing
let me see if i see anybody like that in
here
hippocrates man dude i like it hey you
got
there's no that's the thing about also
about all of this i think the listeners
all recognize
in the end it's all just people you're
just trying your best you're talking so
much you [ __ ] gotta hit you gotta
come against your own taste this idea
that like we gotta be locked into the
way we feel for the rest of our life
like
i know nah bruh you i'm a hypocrite
we're all hypocrites if you say you're
not a hypocrite
you're a [ __ ] hypocrite i want to let
you know that the new be good to
yourself
hoodies are sold out but they'll be back
in stock soon
the original be good to yourself hoodie
is back in stock now
and summertime designs are coming soon
that's right go to theovon.com
store we also would love for you to
contribute
exciting content to the podcast you can
do that through
theovonne.com submit unique tick tocks
and videos and supplements and things
that you see
that's right or you can email them to
tpwproducer
gmail.com thank you for being a part of
the podcast
today's episode is brought to you by
liquid death
this episode is brought to you by modify
and the last website you'll ever need
yep it's the last website you will ever
need think about that think about a
website
and that's the only time you need to do
it because modify will take it
from there they're like a warm blanket
of comfort
once you get involved with them they
built my website
theovonne.com you don't have to do
anything
modify's last website plan features no
cost to build
no contract 45-day turnaround unlimited
revisions and support easy editing tools
free redesigns satisfaction
guaranteed all for just 249 dollars a
month
yep 249 dollars a month
it really seems to be good to be true
can't take my sight off of you
yep and they'll fix your logo up too
that's right to learn more
about the last website you'll ever need
visit
modify.com theo and get a 250
credit when you subscribe for your
world-class website
again that's modify with a
p-h-m-o-d-i-p-h-y
dot com slash theo these guys don't f
around gang yeah we had gotten
coincidence in our town which was cool
yeah
you just work at the bed bath and beyond
that was you had a bed bath and beyond
yeah it's pretty bougie store yeah it
was in slot it was in um
slidell which was like the town here
that's my dude we should go camp out at
the mall we would go there
go to the mall and then camp in a tent
outside and go back in the next day
why yeah just to be at the mall man the
mall was sick the mall was
good did you enjoy your childhood
i think i did in hindsight it was just
scary i felt like it was scary because
like a lot of dangerous
kind of whites and dangerous blacks i
felt like i was also like real scared so
i think i was like scared of everything
you know but i was also like you know
and i could do anything i wanted there
was nobody keeping
you know like you know i was supposed to
drink milk and [ __ ] be alive for like
15 years like that was like kind of the
[ __ ] guidance no one took care of you
yeah there was just no
like like everything was like yeah it
was just kind of like
nobody ever checked in to see what was
going on it was just [ __ ]
it was like somebody started me at the
top of a hill
i may check in with you sometime but in
high tide it was fun you know yeah
but we lived in a fun area man we lived
in a fun area we speak about it a lot
and i think in a way that's um
i don't know loving and like cherished
but the stories
can often be traumatizing but i don't
know it seems like you're kind of happy
with them
yeah i think for a long time i wasn't
because i think they were traumatizing
and then you've kind of dealt with them
and accepted them yeah i just think as i
grow older i realize that
well also we need good stories there's
not a lot of people out there telling
stories anymore
it's almost like in hollywood everything
gets so like chopped down i feel like a
lot of times that they don't let you
tell the good story or even the true
story
like you can't tell a story like and you
can't tell a story a lot of
even true stories about like race and
stuff sometimes because they act like
sometimes as a white person if you say
the word
black or if you say it or if you say
something about like like two of my best
black friends got killed by other black
guys right
yeah so i don't like
that [ __ ] makes me mad right when i see
a lot of stuff like first 48 and those
type of shows where there's a lot of
black on black crime and you see
there's white people making money off
the show i'm sure whoever if you follow
the makers of the show
yeah it's gonna get a little funny he's
not going back into the community
yeah it's not right right it's not going
into [ __ ] memphis
and let's just say memphis okay i think
memphis needs it yeah
they're just going i hope someone gets
murdered in this 48 hour period because
that's what the show is there's a
producer of that show that is going to
work every week going i hope someone
gets murdered jesus christ
that's a tough way to go oh damn it's
easter [ __ ] it's always slow around this
time of year you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah
dude groundhog's day we're gonna have
another three weeks of winter or
whatever yeah
but i just like i feel like sometimes
it's like if i say
that man i feel like sometimes it's just
it scares me how much black on black
crime there is that people think that
i'm against
like like i want black people to live
and prosper i don't it's not like i'm
gonna
then think it's a like that black people
are bad does that make any sense
yeah i think that the tricky thing with
that is just like
all crime is usually committed within
the same race
because most people just live around
their race right so i think the term
to a lot of people is like well black
and black crimes
and white on white crime like white
people are murdering white people like
all these serial killers
often are just murdering white chicks
like you watching these documentaries
just a white dude murdering white chicks
that's not white and white crime that's
easy too let's be honest dude dude was
so easy where's the white dude murdering
black chicks
bro that that right there
that right there that would be hard to
do [ __ ] tuskegee airmen yeah
you need like you need yeah
you're gonna need a plane all these
serial kills are [ __ ] bro
you're just going after white chicks go
to the hood richard ramirez
[ __ ] ass [ __ ] that's true
these black chests are fighting back
[Applause]
they had this white girl in my classical
run up i could not breathe deep without
this chick
seeing me from across the [ __ ] class
like she just
always had a beat on whatever i was
doing i think she thought i could maybe
you know just end up being a crazy
person or something so i just
anytime i even like would be like i
[ __ ] noticed you [ __ ] yes
yes we're not shooting at the school
today no
no no
maybe black on black because maybe you
just see more i mean maybe it's because
there's shows like that
you know yeah i don't know but i mean
there's there's no doubt that there's
black and black right i don't think
anybody denies that
right but what i hate is or maybe it's
could all be in my head but it's like if
i say that
i feel someone's like oh then people
think i'm against black people it's like
no no no i don't think that i want black
people yeah i want
i just want everybody yeah you know that
there's a disproportionate amount of
crime in that community
and you just want that to stop right
yeah it just like bums me out
and it seems almost like there's way
more news or media attention to when
like uh
the police do something to a black
person than when black people are
affected within their own community it
just seems that way because
the media is selling the the sexiest
story like yeah right now
stop asian hate is the story and a few
years ago it was
anti-muslim violence was the story right
so anything happened to a muslim
that was the or slim we call them slims
you know what i mean raleigh you get a
lot of asian hate wherever you're from
you get it
i don't and we got a real asian right
here and what do you say about it
uh if somebody throws something at you
that's hate right
yeah what they throw at you no but i'm
just saying if i'm trying to see what is
asian hate
uh i know it's shootings that's easy
yeah man it's tricky with the asian hate
though because the
the tough thing about asians is like
they're like asians that are
here way longer than maybe either of us
like they've just been here forever
but because they look asian i think
there are certain americans that just
don't see them as american
you know just for whatever reason like i
think the idea of america for a lot of
people
is white and black even non-racist
people they're just like white and black
people that's what makes up americans
right and everybody else just kind of
got to like pick a an identity or side
so if you're asian or if you're like
indian or you're
what's another one i don't know some
other one you just gotta go
how am i gonna act am i gonna act kind
of like culturally white or am i going
to act culturally black
oh that's true well i think but and also
some of it is just because those are our
two kind of
leading vibes in the country and they're
the most they're the most prevalent and
they've been here the longest yeah
right so everybody kind of try to i'm
sure if we moved if i moved to china i
started looking like one of the days
i get i i will get a little bit chinese
yes i'll start to kind of
yeah i'll do just little things that i
see them do a little bit yeah
i start to do it i move quickly [ __ ] on
the sidewalk yeah yeah yeah dude i'll do
it but i'll take a [ __ ] on the sidewalk
sit down i'll cough it in my [ __ ]
child's mouth
so it doesn't get out into the air but
they'll do that kind of stuff bro
the chinese dog let's let's be honest
about the chinese like
that's one thing i don't like sometimes
it's like america we have to make every
moment in america
acceptable for everyone in some magical
[ __ ] way yeah bro
you go to [ __ ] dude i went to a bar i
went to
china they don't give up bro you die in
china
they make a [ __ ] soup out of you they
feed the [ __ ] people are hungry
bro they cruise yeah [ __ ] moves on dog
[ __ ] i mean and they'll do that in an
eight minute set bruh
and that's just how they they don't it's
not like life doesn't i'm not saying
it's their lives aren't as important as
anybody else but
life doesn't the way we feel about life
doesn't mean it's not we're in the
angels and important yes
and everybody should care about us and
there
the community is more important and the
individual
is not as valued and the individual
serves the community i think the idea
of the mask is not you're gonna get me
sick
the idea of the mask is i'm sick i might
get
you sick and i don't want to be a burden
on my community
that's the asian idea the mask which is
pretty lit when you think about it
but of course when we see agents with
mass like five years ago like or three
years
before corona we're just like michael
jackson fan
yeah michael jackson fan or we're just
like what are you trying to say are our
airs dirty
right yeah what are you trying to say we
got we got disease like we saw it as an
insult
instead of them being considerate oh
yeah yeah and that's part of it just the
vibe in america is like
individual i can do whatever without me
and we've had so much freedom
yeah we've had so we have experience for
freedom freedom is lit
if you know what freedom is but if you
never have freedom you don't
care right you know what i'm saying
right oh yeah like you don't know what
you're missing
exactly like there i'm sure there's guys
that do some like crazy sex move or
whatever like that right and like
once they know what it is they love it
their girl loves it but like i don't
know what that is i don't know that so i
don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm missing out so i'm
good yeah and i think that's what
we think people in china are like don't
you miss this freedom you gotta do
whatever the government tells you and
they're like we never had freedom yeah
this is all we know and everybody around
us gets this same [ __ ] so it's fine
yeah and it works it works and i'm one
who starts to wonder if maybe we're
getting to the part of capitalism where
things don't really work as cool as it
once did you think about that sometimes
yeah cause like i wonder if like
capitalism
is just like your teenage years right
and then like like because america's
young like those people got to realize
like this is a good podcast man i just
realized this is fun this is fine
but like america's so young bro like
europeans i think a lot of times they
like judge us right
and europeans i think yeah they got all
the history they got all the ships
but i'm telling like that's why i said
i'm like guys
one we don't care because nobody cares
about y'all but at the same time like
you had thousands of years to develop
your culture in ways right
we're figuring it out we just got money
all of us
yeah we're poor everybody came from
poverty
like yeah my dad probably came for a
little money but if you go to his dad or
his dad
poor my mom poor right everybody in
america is a few generations
or 99 of people are a few generations
away from
dirt poor yeah so we got some money so
we're going to spend the money
reflection right now except you see what
the slims are doing out there in the
middle east right molly perkins yeah
yeah building islands out of sand they
look like they're building
they're making cold sounds damn they
figured it out
but you're right it's like yeah we're in
this teenage years but i wonder how does
this [ __ ]
like go into socialism i i don't even
like saying it because it sounds like
some like bernie [ __ ] or whatever like
we gotta give everybody money blah blah
but i think what happens is it becomes
like europe is a
thousand years ahead of us right and i
think they're like
okay in order for us not to have this
crazy division
in order for us not to be killing
everybody in order for us not to
everybody hate each other
we kind of need to spread the wealth in
a way and provide
health care in a way where everybody has
a decent opportunity
at success in this country that's i
think that's what it eventually
gravitates to because there's a reason
every [ __ ] country in europe has the
kind of similar socialist system and
every country in europe is a few
thousand years old
so i assume we don't have to force it
now but i assume
we will slowly gravitate towards that
and we kind of are already when you
think about it
but a lot of that is also rich people
just hiding behind the government to
make poor people feel okay
yeah which is also okay uh
yeah i don't i don't know exactly i
don't know the long-term effects of that
though
rich people hiding behind the government
to make poor people feel okay what does
that mean again
i don't know is that socialism i don't
know exactly what socialism is i think
it's just tax a little bit more and like
giving poor people a little bit more so
they're not struggling right right
right and i think we're in a yeah like
and i think there's also going to be
some disconnection
letting poor people struggle here
because i think on the back of our heads
we're like
yo we need more 30 for 30s
to be honest with you yo europe got to
trash his 30 for 30s bro
they should have had way better ones but
they don't their 30 30s were like
christopher columbus yeah
like their 30 30s was like joan of arc
you know
if you go back a thousand years bro
their 30 30s were lit
louie the [ __ ] 13th or whatever like
the 14th baby 14th 13th dude [ __ ] dude
13th had asthma and they killed him for
it
bro dude show up
what was he doing who was so strenuous
who knows he's the king
that's the best job yo why don't
oh yeah a single breath bro yeah
yeah yeah we don't want it yeah getting
out of here bruh
yeah that was it dog dude we should have
a castle bruh
fire ass 30 for 30 from back in the day
we should have a castle
i think we got some castles yeah but yo
once we got here we're like yo castles
are hard to build like
[ __ ] stone i think that's what america
really broke away from europe
to do just build [ __ ] out of wood yeah
yeah that's not a bad thought
that's stone [ __ ] it looks cool
but it's heavy dog it's heavy but then
think about the manliness back then
you know we soft now people got pvc
pipe it used to be used to have to fill
your mouth up and [ __ ]
put in your next buddy's mouth you know
what i'm saying old school plumbing bro
you know what i'm talking about speak
for yourself dog someone's still out
here
kicking it whatever dude you want
someone to let you in
one more question man before we let this
beautiful fella get off the hook man
what else we got here uh
um [ __ ] i don't even know this guy's
name man raleigh male here comes a young
fella right here
what up theo what up schultzy gosh got a
quick question for you
no you both are new to ufc and
want to see which one of your superstars
would uh win
if y'all did a tag team match theo and
dustin
or sultsy in israel
i'll beat that baby's ass i'll say this
dude and no offense man beautiful child
bro
dude i'll tell you this nobody picks
being friends with better ufc fighters
[Music]
of all the [ __ ] guys out there who
look like they've been attacked by
[ __ ]
dogs and we picked some [ __ ]
kings that's a great ass point man it's
a good point man
yeah i don't know that one i mean it's
tough that one's tough man because uh
you know theo's got theo's got his super
powers bro like if you go full rat king
it might be a short day of work you know
what i mean because we got rabies baby
you might you might gnaw on me or you
know you might do something i just don't
know how to combat that at all
so you might take me out but then izzy
might have an advantage over dustin just
because of the size
yeah so it it might it's tricky bro it's
a really tricky one man
yeah i think when you get into those
type of guys
and the the size is big i mean look at
izzy versus blockovich you know
the size just when you don't think about
the fact of somebody with 10.
laying on you it's a lot of extra weight
on their feet
the fight was even yeah but the second
he got him down there's just nothing he
could do
and there's nothing you can do and it's
like that's why that's why they have the
weight divisions there you know but uh
but kudos to i mean look that's where in
boxing you can get away with
weight division stuff a little bit more
because you can be tactical you don't
got to hurt the guy you might not be
able to hurt the guy in a higher weight
class but you can out box them
but when it comes to mma those the
weight
when you're laying on top of someone
yeah there's only so much you could just
lift off of you
right you know and especially when it
gets strategic like you know when people
are strategically placing their weight
yeah yeah yeah it's big man and
especially if you're new to having that
weight you know
yeah but um what do you think about
dustin fighting uh
conor again it looks like that's gonna
happen yeah it doesn't really happen i
think it's a smart fight for dustin man
i mean obviously you know it's a smart
fight for him
i hope that the fight happens that's
what i start to worry
i start to uh i mean dustin just works
so hard he just deserves to have the
rewards that he wants
and i think he's starting to kind of
like
it's interesting once you get to certain
points in your career you start to see
some rewards what matters and also what
some rewards matter to you at certain
times
i think i know where you're going with
this but go you know i think sometimes
you're like
okay like when you're younger you know
i need the belt i need the belt i want
the trophy i deserve to be
recognized we want recognition and then
once i think you also get enough
recognition and you get to a point where
you see
okay i also want to be rewarded and be
able to take care of myself and my
family
and so i think it's it's um and
and in the end you start to realize
everything's kind of a business it's
also
it's kind of the it's we get romanced by
that belt bro and i've always been
i'm a helpless romantic you know i
always it's one thing i never liked
about sometimes about like
going to hollywood is you see behind the
curtain like i loved in the heat of the
night because it was like
it was a tv show about like this
community and it was real to me man
and carol o'connor was like the sheriff
and he like cared about the
he cared about the convicts and about
and there was like race stuff going on
but everybody was trying their bed
just like it felt like a and but then
you get there
and i drive across my neighborhood and
carol o'connor's [ __ ] buried right
there and his son
apparently was doing heroin down the
street it's just like you know what i'm
saying the
the the curtain goes away and you start
to see the things a lot of things that
we built
even the magic of things is a business
yeah so i think in some of it you just
keep the magic alive for yourself you
have to keep that alive in your heart
and i start to then wonder who can keep
that magic alive and their heart better
at this point in their careers out of
dustin
and connor and i believe that dustin can
do it better
um because uh connor i mean dude he
gotta think [ __ ] i gotta get up and
[ __ ] sell liquor
in two hours i think he's done i don't
know if he fights again
i i think that would be the only
inhibitor to a third fight
is conor willing to do it because i
don't know
i mean dustin i thought beat him pretty
easy i thought it was pretty easy
and i think that it's an easy fight for
dustin again
and um i don't i don't know
i i and listen i don't think conor has
carried
his power through
the higher weight divisions like when he
was at 145
it was lights out then 155 it was like
i need to hit you a few times okay man
we will you shut the lights out
would you do me a favor just wait a
little bit and then then we'll go
one second no it's for that weird dimmer
switch saying you're like how do you get
this never even goes all the way
how do you get this to go off so i i
but again like you said like he's he's
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
the only reason he would do it i think
would be for more money and yeah go get
your money i want these guys to make all
the [ __ ] money
i'm just happy that it looks as if i
don't know him but it looks as if dustin
went
what does that belt really mean like
does the belt define
me as a human being no it's like a cool
trinket to have in my career
but you know it'd be really cool uh if i
was defined by like being able to take
care of generations of my family
yeah by doing this mega fight and making
tens of millions of dollars
that would be a cool way to be defined
by going like the poiriers
that are my kids and their kids and
their kids all going to nice private
schools
and our community is going to be helped
out and his foundation is going like
that is way better than a belt now
he could beat connor then go fight the
winner of
the title fight that there's like
chandler versus oliveira i think they're
fighting yeah yeah
and and then he gets the belt awesome
but secure the bag
bro like secure the [ __ ] bag
i i hope that that is what i want all
these guys to make all it's a brutal way
to make a living
yeah i want you all to make all the
[ __ ] money
that's that's what i think too i and i
bet honestly a little bit i bet it was a
little bit of a tough decision for
dustin because he still wants that he
has hardware right
him and uh him and tony ferguson were
gonna fight and they didn't
reward though it just wasn't they didn't
feel like they got were
being rewarded fair like he tries to you
know he tries to be as fair and treat
people as fair
you know so i bet it was a little
[ __ ] tough for him
but yeah but i think as you get further
along
look dude yeah like you said just let
them fight for the belt though
i agree just let them fight for the
[ __ ] belt dana like who can i agree
you make it a title fight you put in a
[ __ ] dallas cowboy stadium like who
cares it's the first event that we get
to see live
like yeah i don't know why they didn't
do that
look but you're right though the
fouriers will be the
rich ease and that is that's what's
[ __ ]
you know the older you get you start to
realize it's not about being rich but
it's about being able to [ __ ] like
provide
being able to provide for yourself and
your family is a very comforting feeling
because
as you get older your families have
issues like your [ __ ] parents start
to get old they need help you know what
i mean
your brothers your cousins they need
assistance in their life they go to
[ __ ] jail you know they have some
sort of like mental issues whatever like
you need some disposable income so you
could [ __ ] help these people out yeah
and unfortunately dustin god
you're the one like sometimes god puts
it on you for the family yeah
so that's another thing we have to
realize like you know when it's a
blessing and a curse you're like oh [ __ ]
you know i'm the one that's gonna have
to finish college i'm the one that's
gonna have to do this
or you know or you know um but yeah man
it's it's awesome to see man both those
fighters are awesome to see
they're both totally different izzy and
dustin
but they're both uniquely i think
beloved by people
yeah great personalities just great fun
you know i'm looking forward to izzy
coming back to middleweight because i
just think he's gonna
i think these middleweights now are
gonna have this like renewed confidence
because they saw him struggle for the
first time
and i think that the audience actually
needs
to believe that he's beatable because
the fights were going to get
uninteresting because he was so dominant
yeah i think they need to go oh he they
might have his number now
try to wrestle him now and then he comes
out there he just [ __ ] destroys them
all
right yeah yeah it's yeah yeah watching
him is just it's insane
himber's darren tale is gonna be if they
do that just on social media is gonna be
so much fun
i just got my first stripe the other day
at jiu jitsu oh are you doing jiu jitsu
yeah
i got two i think i have two cracked
ribs like two cracked ribs right now
which is one of the reasons i've been
able to go but uh this week but i just
got my first strike
and you enjoy the exercise yeah it's
really fun everybody tries it loves it
yeah i like it it's just
it's tough on your body it's a little
bit tough really yeah i had a five
they've been having i've fought women
i've fought a
guy who is legally blind last they got
me fighting in the real
you know it's not even a weight class
it's almost like an emotional wellness
group you know
like i'm like what weight class that i'm
in they're like jiu jitsu
yeah like what weight class i'm in like
you're over there behind the water
fountain
okay
so it's a unique group man but
dang dude i get to come down to miami
tell me when you're coming down so i put
it in i promise i'll come down i'll come
down uh
let's do i think maybe first week of may
done
done first week of may i'll come down
raleigh do you have any questions for
this gentleman
uh i do not thanks raleigh
dude appreciate it i'm telling you asian
kids now bro it's a whole different ball
okay they know everything right we got
it no that's not to do unbelievable
what happened the other day you didn't
know riley what was it on that episode
um you don't remember i
don't remember but it's all good imagine
an asian person saying they don't
remember
yeah i know when is that happening it's
bad is it american bro that's another
thing we have
here's the thing that happens in america
people come from another country
okay they're like we all better we you
we're gonna force these kids to learn
spanish so we can communicate with these
newcomers
the second generation of newcomers knows
no [ __ ] spanish
they get american real quick we flip
people real quick dude
you guys are bad friends
you want some let's go
i think we're good you i'm great hey can
we both do it at the same time let's do
it all right
one two three we're a bad friend
okay there we go
dude andrew schultz man congratulations
on all your success man uh brother
yeah you're an inspiration to a lot of
us man and uh i'm just really grateful
that you came in today
i mean i love you bro it's cool to see
you bro it's [ __ ] fun
you know what man when i watch you i'll
say this this is one thing that i do get
i feel like i'm having fun and that's
awesome
all right that makes me feel good that
makes me feel good we're just trying to
have fun out here man
i appreciate you man you know i love you
gang bro get it
now i'm peace floating on the breeze and
i feel
i'm falling like these leaves i must be
cornerstone
oh but when i reach that ground i'll
[Music]
that parking brake and let myself
on my heart shine
that light on me
[Music]
i'll sit and tell you my story
just
and now i've been moving way too fast on
the runaway train with a heavy load of
my
hands
and these whales that i've been robbing
on they want something